so it's my pleasure to introduce Karina
Rex who's the director of the department
of mobility and infrastructure in the
city of Pittsburgh so the mission of the
department that she leads the department
of mobility and infrastructure has the
mission to provide the physical mobility
necessary for the economic mobility of
all Pittsburghers in her role Karina is
responsible for providing safe
accessible sustainable and efficient
transportation options and facilities in
the city she previously served as the
director of transportation planning for
the District of Columbia and the
founding principle of the mid-atlantic
office of the innovative transportation
consultancy Nelson Nygaard associates
leading the firm's multimodal practice
on the East Coast working with cities
and communities across the nation and
globe on integrated implementable
mobility solutions that serve local
values and aspirations she was hired by
Mayor Bill Peduto in 2017 now please
yeah no thank you I was joking with
Mayor Peduto yesterday that when I
interviewed for this job about a year
ago he didn't mention mind blow outs and
landslides as part of the things that
I'd have to deal with here but I'm happy
to be here and learning a lot every day
so I am pleased to be here and
representing the administration of Mayor
Peduto and it has been just about a year
this this week marks my one-year
anniversary of being here in the city
relocating from Washington DC and I have
to say that one of the things that has
made this experience so rewarding and so
special is the partnership that we have
with not only Carnegie Mellon University
but also the University of Pittsburgh
and any number of the institutions here
across the city it is really a rare gift
to have such such highly skilled
world-class institutions that are as
committed to making the city that they
live in a better place as they are to
really pushing the bounds of human
understand
sort of academic exercises and research
and so it's really is a something that
is special that we are fortunate to have
and grateful for insta this metro 21
Institute that's being created we have
had a partnership in place with CMU
since 2014 and that allows us to really
use CMU as an arm of the city that we
can come to them with questions with
challenges to help us address some of
those critical issues I reached out to
the Department of Engineering just
recently at the charge of the mayor who
said I need an asphalt that doesn't
create potholes and I said I'm gonna
call CMU an asphalt that won't at
potholes in it so I'm waiting for that
research thank you but we can bring our
challenges and visions to this
institution and thanks to this we really
are world leaders in things like
applications of autonomous technology
we're seeing it on our streets today
we're seeing how that's applying and how
it can be used in creating that physical
mobility to achieve economic mobility
that we talked about we see the great
adaptive traffic signals that were first
demonstrated here in our city and are
now in cities throughout the country
using that technology that was developed
here pushing it even further we're in
continued partnership with things like
using video analytics for vision zero
for safety to do sort of predictive
interventions before so so experiencing
observing those near misses the things
that we don't even have data on
typically but we can partner with CMU to
use this kind of information to see what
is typically not reported and put
interventions in place before something
happens so really important that we do
that but we also know that smart cities
and the smart city Institute is an
entity that also is one that listens and
observes and understands what the real
world challenges are of the city it's
not just an academic exercise we live in
the real world
have slopes thatthat slide down and put
20,000 cubic yards who soil and on the
roads and needing to figure that out
needing to really challenge how can we
get ahead of that how can we monitor how
can we see what is happening those those
incremental movements in this slope
before something really catastrophic
happens I'm reaching out to this
institution finding out how we can use
that understanding how global climate
change affects things like landslides I
didn't know actually that the landslides
are a consequence of some of the global
climate change that we've experienced so
how do we understand what those
connections are I have feeling bridges
and railings & stairs here in the real
world and and working with this
institution working through the
engineering working through through
materials testing and other kinds of
applications to see you know can we do
things crazy things like 3d print
bridges or use coatings to restore
stairs so we are the testbed we're happy
to be the testbed for this institution
we are as I think has been said before
we're the double black diamond of cities
right if you can do it here you can do
it anyplace across the globe so we're
happy for this partnership we're happy
to be that place to be the real world
but you can test these ideas and we need
the knowledge that this institution and
that this institute brings we're in an
era of big data we're about to get heaps
of it and have no capacity really to
understand that so to partner with this
institution to partner with all of you
in this room to help us understand
what's happening to help us intervene in
ways that really serve the underlying
values of our city and contribute to the
success of our city residents so happy
to be here happy to represent the mayor
looking forward to the next year and
what will happen and fewer landslides if
we can do that so thank you
[Applause]